in this video we'll be talking about the
differences between apoptosis and
necrosis this is a highill topic for
usml step one so stay tuned till the end
so first difference between apoptosis
and necrosis which is the most important
part apoptosis could be physiological or
pathological it could be both but
necrosis is mostly pathological
currently there are no instances that
necrosis is also Associated as a
physiological process now let me remind
you during development apoptosis could
happen for example when our digits are
separated this process requires
apoptosis so apoptosis works as a
sculpture artist during development it
can also occur when a regulating factor
is withdrawn in a proliferating
environment for example when interlukin
2 level drops down then there there is a
apoptosis of the affector T cells so
this is completely normal there is no
pathology associated with it but
apoptosis can also be associated with
pathology it could be both for example
if you have trauma radiation toxin
exposure these factors could lead to
apoptosis now for necrosis to occur it
has to be some sort of infection or some
sort of injury for example isia
reperfusion injury there could be other
categories where there is an absis
development there could be fungal
infection there could be injury or blood
clot Associated uh necrosis or let's say
there is gangrenous infection so there
are different category of necrosis which
one can think of but each of these
category are associated with some sort
of infection or injury if you want to
learn more about the types of necrosis I
have a video on that click on the eye
button but at least you can understand
right now that uh necrosis is always
associated with some sort of pathology
then apop in apoptosis the cell membrane
typically remains in intact that means
the uh B layer remains intact and the
Integrity is not lost but in necrosis it
is lost but before that it is important
to note that in apoptosis the membrane
lipid composition change many membrane
lipid uh categories such as phosphat
serin which was supposed to be in the
inner leflet now is displaced on the
outer lifet here you can see it in the
green so these are uh some lipid
signatures during apoptosis
in necrosis the membrane Integrity is
lost that means there are physical
damage in the plasma membrane which
leads to leakage of fluid or cytoplasmic
material outside and this is not
happening in apoptosis apoptosis though
there is bbing of the cell but each of
these BLB has intact membrane so the
contacts are
confined another peculiar feature about
apoptosis is that inflammation is not in
evoked the cell strings the the cell
dies but there is no inflammation in the
nearby tissue so if there are cells
nearby they won't be harmed but in
necrosis things are different necrosis
in some cases can evoke strong
inflammatory response or tissue damage
then in case of apoptosis the cell size
generally shrinks because the membrane
blbs out and the cell becomes smaller in
size and in case of necrosis the
opposite thing happens the cell swells
up and there is also leakage of fluid
the mitochondria and other organal also
swells up there is another peculiar
factor which is losal rupture the
rupture of lysosome lead to hydrolytic
and protolytic enzyme to be released on
the outside environment of the cell
which is detrimental and can further
evoke inflammation in apoptosis there
are well-coordinated well- defined
Pathways such as intrinsic and extrinsic
pathway which are orchestrated by
specific molecular mediators in context
of necrosis there are not very well-
defined molecular event which controls
the process it's not as programmed as
apoptosis people think there was no
control over necrosis but it's not true
there is some molecular involvement but
the entire procedure is not very well
coordinated from a molecular perspective
another peculiar Factor about apoptosis
be it extrinsic pathway be it in
intrinsic pathway the executor caspace
is the key player in this process the
cliffed caspace 3 is the main player but
caspas activation is never seen in
necrosis so just to remind you about all
these differences let us quickly review
the cellular Hallmark of necrosis and
apoptosis so let's review the necrosis
in case of necrosis mitochondrial
swelling perinuclear localization of
mitochondria is pretty distinct there is
a calcium overload there is plasma
membrane rupture losal rupture excessive
Ross production ATP depletion and
uncoupling of the the uh
Etc now the key points of apoptosis are
the following apoptosis is ATP dependent
program cell pathway the int there is
intrinsic and extrinsic pathway both
Pathways activate caspace so caspace is
the key player then cellular breakdown
happens shrinkage happens membrane blbs
out but the membrane remains
intact the the uh next point is the cell
membrane typically remains unharmed and
there is no inflammation which is evoked
the cell membrane composition changes we
did see distribution of the lipid has
changed and another thing is DNA ladin
that means the DNA becomes fragmented
but still confined in those BBS so I
hope this covers the important
differences between apoptosis and
necrosis all the detailed videos are
linked in the eye button you can quickly
go and click on the on that I think this
video was useful if you like this video
a quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can support our
Channel using super thanks which is a
hardship icon on the bottom right corner
of the video you can click on that and
pay via PTM PayPal or UPI see you in
next
[Music]
video